five standard okay let's let's roll here
five standard boom all right let's go
here let's go let's go let's go let's go
as ready to double the points to try the
Sicilian Sicilian what nie Dorf open
Sicilian most likely or is there gonna
be Bishop b5 no Knight c3 and then
decision time for Black Knight Orff a6
now what many choices for white ok we
are well within theory here and I don't
know a whole lot about it really beyond
this Bishop being on e6 the night
playing here there are some timely there
are some ideas of f3 g4 for white I know
that black has opportunities to maybe
put a halt to that g4 move with h5 and I
think this is a bit off I can't be
certain of it but something tells me
it's a bit off because it's obstructing
the Queen's view of the d5 square and I
don't know that that's a good thing to
be doing because one thing that I have
available to me at least right now is
this d5 move maybe maybe I don't like
doing it right away I don't like that
this night could be making use of the c5
square maybe after capturing or maybe
even doing it immediately
no actually probably capturing first but
just more development this is still
something I am thinking about d5 the
liberating move if f floor is played
I think I chop and then occupy e5 so
what is my opponent have in store for me
are they considering queenside castle
that is my first thought you know
reserving the option they are not yet
giving me they're not yet giving away
the address of their king so to that I
say let's play my Bishop - the only
square could go - and I'm going to
remain flexible with my other moves b5
Queen c7 rook c8 are on my mind here and
here we go so if I don't do something
quickly
I think f5 is gonna force my bishop to
have to take the knight well that's for
certain
and I don't want to give up my light
square bishop so easily so to that I
need to chop and now next up occupy e5
there we go so d5 at any moment this guy
could turn into a monster you could turn
into a monster my opponent is watching
over g4 so I'm getting the sense that
they really do want to Castle queenside
they don't want to deal with this skewer
though understandable
they're very understandable I could chop
this guy at any moment but I like him
too much he's a tall pawn he's a strong
night so what do you do what do you do
what do you do
b5 D for now let's castle lettuce castle
Queen c7 rook c8 b5 be for maybe a 4 8
maybe 85 a for this nights gonna be
coming there there we go okay well
all right my bishop needs to stay put
needs to stay put that bishop maybe I
should have considered like rook e8 or
something is my father gonna Castle yet
what I really just want to know where
they're going okay thank you now I have
at least I'm finding comfort and knowing
that my opponent castled actually
because now I have at least a little bit
more direction I know where he now
resides and I'm coming to get him
let's go King ah who benefits as a
result of this exchange I think I do
because a this Knight no longer has the
opportunity centralized itself on d5b I
have an open file for my rook that
didn't need to do that did not need to
make any moves and it's just all of a
sudden working and well I don't have a
see point to be making so I'm wondering
if my opponent was going for this
because they're seeing that these double
puns are maybe a liability when really
they're fantastic so you know don't
always cringe when you see double puns
look how valuable these guys are look at
how useful this double pun is especially
pawns doubled in the center look at the
squares after controlling f4 f5 d4 d5
this Knight is dead to the game this
bishop same thing where does it go
the knight has one move these two pieces
have a total of one move available to
them now f4 is weakened as a result of
this last square so my thoughts are
being centered around this f4 square and
to start I could play Knightly seven I
would absolutely love to get a knight
right there but I don't see how to
really do that but a rook there would be
good as well or even a bishop so here we
go time to maneuver the night this is a
case of middle game planning at this
point
and what will often be a very good thing
to do in the middle game is find ways to
make peace improvements the placement of
your pieces how can you do better with
their placement my knight definitely
needs some more work I'm doing a couple
things my rook has sight of this square
my bishop could come to here at some
point and this is now all the more
appealing if I could get my bishop here
h6 would facilitate this move the
downside is that I'm providing something
to bite at for my opponent they could
stop my plan of Bishop g5 and they could
then I look to play here at a later
point and open lines up I want to keep
these guys sitting right where they're
out but this is good and I'm going to
double up next or actually I might want
to do something like this that could be
pretty sneaky Bishop to g5 I might have
some tricks up my sleeve oh wait a
second are they planted this I might
have missed that why didn't I realize
that there's some pressure on this file
here let's get out of that oh well all
right so now no no no where is this and
I think it's gonna go oh oh
get out of there Knight you need to go
too but he needs to go home basically go
home Knight next I'm just gonna throw
these a and B pawns down because I can
and because it's good the closer I get
to my opponents pawns the more likely
it's the case I am able to trade open
files I'd like to create a dark shore
weakness and these pawns are I'm not a
fear I'm not afraid of these guys I
could be taking this but I'm just kind
of
I don't I don't care about that I do not
care about that pond push which one do I
go with I got a minute hang on hang on
when are both underman I have a little
bit of an edge timewise love to play
here I get rid of that Bishop hmm oh I
got a sneaky move sneaky move sneaky
move rook takes rook as a loser bishop
here is pretty deadly isn't it it's got
to be Supreme of that I have all these
entry points guarded by the way and the
Queen definitely has to move and the
Queen definitely didn't move so time
pressure time time pressure okay I am
not afraid of coming out in the center
if I could be assured that the queen is
no longer on the board so that's about
it all right
pin and then win of the Queen and pinch
pieces should stay pinned so let's go
with that
the knight is also pinned I'm gonna keep
it pinned Queen isn't gonna go anywhere
okay now we take and then take again I'm
threatening rook takes now we got this
rook takes Oh the whole house the whole
house is going one by one
honey is running still running
check check and close to me right
resignation okay good game Elaine let's
see let us see let me go back let me go
back and we'll see where we could maybe
make improvements here backing up
okay so
nyehhhh Dorf so far so booked I'm not
sure this move really just not sure this
move might want to consider Bishop e2 if
anything and I DS of g4 g5 expansions
I've also I think seen a four but first
you know hang on I think first something
like f3 just to stop maybe even me from
trying like Knight g4 stuff just to
secure this bishops position again I
don't like the fact that this Bishop was
kind of blocking the Queen's view of
this file of the d5 square so I think
there's a 4 there's f3 there's Bishop e2
I'm just not so sure about Bishop d3 I
could be off with that this is maybe
still line you know the white is
definitely doing well they're getting
other pieces out but I think things
definitely start to go astray in this
middle game and in fact as soon as that
move was played I'm almost a hundred
percent certain that black is better
it's just too valuable upon right now to
have it's like this one pun is taking
out your knight it's and it's not
accessible how to even get at it and
then giving up the dark square Bishop
this is definitely good for me these
double pawns are very valuable very very
valuable so the improvement is maybe
this how about after queenside castling
b5 don't take that instead maybe it's
worth considering something like how
about g4 about g4 and then Knight to f5
look at how much different things would
be then g4 and then maybe this Knight f5
move which is in my territory you know I
start to cringe whenever I see piece on
one of my four ranks to the board and
you should too for your chess player
really because it's like the beginning
of bad things happening to you so I
think g4 and the knight here if I take
you recapture towards the center and
then you have a file to work with and if
I don't take well I have a lot of
pressure on me doing that I think that's
something to look into
I think